I am very pleased with the success of this 51st All Japan Aikido Demonstration.
Last year was the miletsone event of the 50th All Japan Aikido Demonstration.
This wonderful art created by Aikido founder,
and transmitted by the 2nd Doshu Kisshomaru and the pioneers of the art,
has evolved and thanks to you, thanks to all Aikidoka,
it now forms circle larger than ever.
This year, it is with a new momentum,
aand a renewed passion, that you have come to practice, honoring the circle.
With respect to its history and evolution,
we have a duty to transmit Aikido, and continue to expand this circle.
I will now offer a demonstration to close the event.